cliff where do you want to start this
morning well you know what that Prescott
conversation is pretty cool that I he
stays in there for me to rest of the way
yeah yeah you know I look I really like
I roll I just don't think that the when
you talk about chemistry don't disrupt
that Dan especially in time again when
subo this is my thoughts did you ever
have a situation where maybe a veteran
got hurt young guy came in and then the
veteran comes back and then the locker
room is split on should that guy play
again you know you know the funny thing
is the old-school Wally PIPP stores you
know you don't you know a veteran gets
hurt and then this youngster comes up
and he's like a stud nearby joking haha
you got Wally PIPP you know and it it's
what yeah it's a running locker but it's
all fun and games it's like you know you
know the veterans coming back you held
down the fort that's why you have you
know the 25-man roster or whatever or
the miley system is full of guys is
waiting for a chance or unfortunate
situations somebody get hurt so yeah you
have that but it's just you know what
you it's a little bit different I think
well in baseball you have a hundred six
or two games so you going to need these
youngsters and football totally
different it's short you know 16 weeks
is I wait hold up you notice this is
feeling good and looking good but we'll
see what happened also the second time
around we see a lot of pitchers who were
great that first time through and then
they face a team the next time around
and then that's when you got to adapt I
don't know if that's going to happen to
dak Prescott but is there any similarity
between a quarterback and a starting
pitcher I do I think especially you know
this time of year um so much as doubt
into you know you know what he does well
and what he don't do well right and then
once you dial into all right this guy's
really good yeah you start you start
putting them on the board a little bit
differently and putting up more
information so the second time to align
for pictures you know as good as mine
just throw out Madison Bumgarner he
probably unfair to throw out but you
know maybe a guy like Marco Estrada you
know where you going re we know he has a
changeup we know he has this pitch but
second time through is you're going to
get cute and try to now throw it
changeup little bit more because that's
his out-pitch you know or is he going to
stick with fast balls been successful
you know once you once you have these so
certain things that come up it's more
magnified right now and as players
you're always trying to figure out just
a little i need is a little crack in the
door so I can bust it down or you know
let's see how much pressure we can put
on him to make him make that mistake if
you allow him to continue to be great
guess what he's going to be the MVP of
that series or he's going to be a guy we
have conversations about you know should
you start you know Tony Romo or we still
go to the syllabus then plan right now
he's cliff Floyd major league baseball
Network will exclusively air game 3
between the Nationals and Dodgers today
you can watch cliff on MLB tonight
throughout the postseason you have these
pictures we had the conversation when
Bumgarner threw the great great game in
the wild-card certain guys get up it's
not like he's been a substandard or an
average pitcher during the regular
season but to elevate what is it that
you see or what is different that
certain pitchers are able to elevate and
certain ones can't but they use your
breasts of the aggressiveness huginn she
and that's what he does now to your
point real quick and I want to take up a
lot of time but I think you make a great
point he's different now to this
postseason this year right and and I had
I had numbers I never talked about
numbers but this is interesting because
I kept said all these bullpens are
coming in the game in the fifth inning
and before last night's game you know
nine or 20 pitches then failed to
complete five innings this postseason 12
of 20 starting pitchers have thrown five
or fewer inning now when you talk about
the full season you talking about the
elite Oh
Lee great this is not there three four
five guys of your rotation so when you
told matt baume & Air Corps of course
he's number one a list of law nine in it
because he went there and the wild-card
game but then you start looking at a
name that haven't went completed five
meter you know Darvish half you know
Kershaw Bauer rich hill / solo tenor art
I mean all these names you going in
there you going wow this is this is
crazy but you know you're talking about
guys this from offensive side it's
paying a ton of attention to what these
guys do well and what we can't do the
one thing Madison Bumgarner does is he
has a game plan he sticks to it you
heard him talk about it I threw all I
through fast balls for any or almost two
innings and then I went to my off-speed
stuff I'm sorry thinking about Who am I
mind from you know when I face a guy
like him with the mindset was that
intelligent enough to understand that
you have to stick to the game plan and
it was Greg Magus from the right side
and when I thought about Greg must I
thought man this dude never pitched me
the same no matter what I was a national
legal for life but he uses always the
things that you're going to think he's
going to do any flips annoying so so
that's what am I play makes my bum that
good you played for one year with the
Cubs right 07 yeah what are you really
what is that feeling like when you go to
the ballpark and and the fans almost
feel like it's a impending doom there or
did did you sense that and you finished
first that you're right yeah yeah we've
been finished we finished first lost
three games straight to a young d-backs
teen right then and you I mean you can
hear a pin drop in that place when we
lost at home when it what there is all
lost to came home lost Irwin it's
wrapped the home so what the Texas
Rangers did you know felt that that you
you can see you know the faces I felt
Jonathan Lucroy face or feelings you
know last night when we heard him
talking about you know after the game
Jeff bastard pretty much has the same
face all the time which I love
but you can feel how disappointed and I
didn't envision I really did not i
thought the range gone further than is i
thought you know toronto limping to the
postseason and oh they got there and if
any back they win but they limped people
are playing great baseball but in
chicago is almost like everything they
hung their hat on every situation I mean
it went when a ball fell in there was
just a regular they said it was like aw
you shouldn't open it correct I'm like
well that was just a regular basis
because that's part of the game so you
know I think you have to understand you
know as a player you have to sort of put
blinders on you have to put earplugs in
and you have to play and you know you
the first game in that series I mean
every Chicago Cubs fan was at that game
thinking there's no way are we bout to
lose this game Johnny Cueto talked about
it anyway anyone out there and walked it
he pitched a great game just didn't get
near on support from a team that
struggled off this that's what you're
going up against in Chicago it's just
the pressure of them hanging on to every
pitch every situation I do know the
postseasons about that when Chicago is
manufacturing more who's going to the
World Series I do have them gone I
really do I my suit my Road series is no
Cubs Red Sox but well my Red Sox
situation ain't looking too too bright
right now not know that's what happens
then you know what real quick you know
what the Indians remind me of they
remind me of the 08 Tampa Bay Rays
grinding grit no superstars you know you
have a few lift up and coming we had
Evan Longoria at third base was our
budding superstar you know you have
Francisco Lindor just if you don't knock
them out and you heard Hanley talk about
book your tickets back to come you know
back to Cleveland well you better book
some some runs and you better book them
fast against Tomlin or it's going to be
a wrap cliff good to talk to you enjoy
the rest of the post
thanks for joining us the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience